[Applaus]
[Musik]
er ist 17 jahre polizist
die hand gottes billiger kommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das klar
[Musik]
gott im alltag oder schreit eine frau
mit kindern umher
bestätigungsmail die komoren
für die ifa prix vor der polizei aus
landschaft sind blaulichtfahrten alltag
wie viel hat der autark mit der
vorstellung vor seine junge kolleginnen
und kollegen
und luigi spiegelt
[Musik]
das allerdings schnell hochladen
aber haben sie noch eine kleine saison
sind
daher ist dir die zähne
der rallye mal bitte druckst
beschuldigung wenn sie mal zurück
zurückgeführt
[Musik]
er gehört wer gehört zur familie
mit
was ist immer was passiert
[Musik]
also patientin ist eindeutig sagen und
das ist doch nicht da ich gerade meinen
pc wird
wenn die lehrer und
wir sehen das natürlich öfters in der
medizin ist und physisch sehr stabil und
der ist mal klar ist man aufgeregt und
hat angst um die person
[Musik]
niveau im sanitätswagen ich ja meinen
dass ich wäre doch ja also haben sie vor
sich august wie es haben sich einen
ausweis
bleiben sie bitte mal schnell hier
stehen
ein bisschen beruhigen
2009 ist das 2001 ok also das ist alles
haben auf ihre fragen
[Musik]
was
hat dir traurig dass medizinisches
problem oder ist sie opfer von meiner
verbrecher wurde das wird jetzt im
spital abgeklärt was dort um sach und
effektiv spielt für den ist der fall
erledigt nachtschicht gott wieder
luzerner seetal talent polizei
basel-landschaft und sie konnten von der
central und nordwestschweiz ihren
nachwuchs ausbilden
[Musik]
der interkantonale polizeischule
hitzkirch hat er steht corona virus fern
und strom im netzteil lockte die
praktische ausbildung wird zum beispiel
findet wieder dorf rot statt oli
theoretische sache muss man sich
selbständig im fernstudium erarbeiten
mit leads panik in die luft
[Musik]
ich bin über die lage trifft sie
schwimmt wie durch sonja und vor allem
letzte chance
gehabt haben ihr viertes foul und ich
sagte ja noch nie in gefahr die blutbahn
ja definitiv aufgeregt hält die
schießprüfung
diana staehly vor der polizei aus
landschaft hat die letzten wochen
erinnert immer die schwarze prof
entsprechend groß ist der
[Musik]
hit der bee kaymer wiederholen wer das
zweite motorrad fliegt
[Musik]
das ist doof ehrenrunde xxi
ja jetzt nicht lachen aber noch höher
der technik habe bis jetzt ist sie
selbst ob liebe
vielen dank so muss für alle klar
ist der
ganze kreis inclusive ist ich sage ich
sage
konzentrieren der ko vor den auftrag
alles andere gibt sich noch
[Musik]
unklar
jetzt
wo die nächste chance alles
und er sagt wir lang mit elf ziele
[Musik]
darüber was ich für den
mittelstand
den vater 1 2 3 4 5
6 5 geführt
was für
eine vorhand
katja öffne dich eine 50 50 doch außer
schreibt ist so vielleicht
[Gelächter]
später erfährt sie note 5
nachtschicht vor ihren kollegen in die n
stück wieder
[Musik]
ohne mampf kein kampf
tradition ich finde das nicht zum
nachteil
mitbringen
[Gelächter]
in der pause des
minis muss man ans labor vertrauen
vertreter und stiefel sechziger
hat wenn es um gott die schützer wenn
der in bedrängnis und der brown griff zu
halten und noch schlimmer
noch chef von publicis mobiliar und ich
am morgen am hobby 7 fertig
es ist schon weit nach mitternacht
h12 wenn wir das nicht - er läuft den
vorschlägen java farbe nicht keine hüfte
gestemmt
körper wird mir wird ist dass das zarte
und ging auf die fünf junge einen kurzen
einigermaßen wieder rauskommst sachs ist
aber so zieht so ab der 12
zum beispiel
wie vor herrscht sowieso 1 2 gold/3
sodann
und noch viel schneller
als neuling denkmal der unregelmäßige
orbiter unterschätze die säcke belastend
für ein sauberes umfeld
politisch
der polizeischule hitzkirch
jeden tag am morgen habe auch die a- und
ich noch die 4 nötig
machen
und sie macht gang zu
jetzt da ich nur gezerrt in such gemacht
spalter nur durch gespart jetzt schon
viele male besucht und nach
erledigt machen natürlich
vorgehen innerhalb des objektes heißt
das ausbildungsmodul
[Musik]
diana staehly schlägt sich als klassik
spenden
[Musik]
vertretbar schweizer exporte schwarze
bluse liegt ja doch jeder oder
naja ich fahre mal passiert ja genau
sehr gut und wenn sie so stehen
das eigentlich wirklich nur der brite
von sich zwingen uns wieder lockte er
möglich dass du wirklich nicht gesehen
das hängt mir zum beispiel der
geiselnahme brauche
probieren alt ist wie beides
gleichzeitig
und ich würde
also ein realistischer nutze den stich
situation so dass die gelernt der muster
waren der polizei schon kennt das dir
halt zum teil liter super dass es nicht
immer bis zur schlosserei gut zum glück
es wird er das maximum trainiert und in
realistischer alltagsleben als polizist
hört die schwelle zum glück vor eine
frau baumann muss bereits eventualitäten
das ist natürlich gegen oben luft hat
die denn
die nacht
ist auch jetzt so an die wand in
der stadt einen tankstellenshop in
laufen sollte es noch
weitere nationen
auch
kriminellen frage dass mit profis krise
wahrscheinlich aus frankreich
da weiß man hier das
sprengmittel den vollständig synthetisch
also merkel sich unter vertrag bevor
spezialisten das auflegt haben das
eigene hab ich natürlich selbst etwas
klar
zu verletzen dadurch muss ich selber leo
punkt keinen sinn
das land ist im grenzkanton drum hat
polizei regelmäßig mit dem umliegenden
ausland
wir sind häufig sehr professionell und
schon brutal
direkte kontakt heißt das will polizei
herrscht die vorsicht
patrouille ist zufällig am tatort
vorbeigefahren und wurden schnell
persönlich biologe
[Musik]
andere wird jetzt leider kann man so
einen überfall von der bank kann man das
daran dass
medizin nicht so helfen wir vielleicht
zu
tragen haben auch gerade bei besserer
schalterdienst wo wegen der drogen nimmt
freud und leid alles zusammen in
geballter ladung und genau dann wenn man
es nicht erwartet das macht spannend
automaten bombe sind immer häufigeren
schweiz unterwegs
[Musik]
risiko aber große bietet die aktion eher
klassisch bank hat mit der pistole am
schalter mehr oder weniger abgelöst in
ganz europa
[Musik]
mit der geldmaschine also eine vorhand
jeweils 14 abziehen oder ganz zu fassen
das muss man jetzt alles zellen sind als
neuer
stammpilot oder ungenau und ramona tiere
wie viel geld das
richtige tat tot sind sagt
viel häufiger hans zum beispiel mit
süßlicher gold tour
häusliche gewalt erlebt man immer wird
oder indien stehe
aber nicht sagen ob das wöchentlich oder
monatlich einmal erleben halsbach dass
wir dazu gefunden darunter model trifft
eine andere parole aus wir jetzt die
situationen frauen kinder im spiel sind
wenn sie vor ort sind und dass man so
eine oder mehrere staaten dass das wenn
die freundin so muss miterleben
hit gar zum hd also riesig war der
polizeischule hitzkirch
20 36 e qualifiziertes jahre geschieht
über 50 pro tag
gewalt stopp bestanden
dass die primär auftrag von gewalt
stoppen dennoch lockt je nach situation
heute
passiert da
war schnell gestritten und macht man im
alter.de schreibt dass eine ära bieten
das wildtieren auf gott gefasst hat
nicht nur
probleme das ist falsch
sinn und zweck erfüllt aber massive
türen
geschwindigkeit
kennzeichnet nie verstanden
da unten ist dass ich dort auf
rendite zu holen wenn sie zum ersten mal
begegnet brücke dass die noch verblieben
standen und an das jetzt wenn es nicht
gelingt wird es mit hause nach der
theorie dann die praktisch ewig
verweile polizei was landwirte tag das
mich nach oben
die frage was landgrebe
einander wirklich muss probiere der
software ruhige wovon einer klasse
schwindlig gespielt wird
wir haben ja
ganze flasche los wenn sie diese
kompromisse
stehen die software steht und die
sicherheit
nein wir sind
neugierig neue rolle denn ando wirklich
jetzt der schläger sie mit klassik
spendieren den korrekt über seine rechte
und pflichten aufklären bevor sie
also wenn ich sie jetzt auskunftsperson
bzw staatlichkeit der gti von einer
hinsicht sind sie nicht so lustig
verpflichtet wenn sie keine zauberer
oder innen aussehen die person aber laut
stadt aber wenn sie nun sagen hat muss
sie der wahrheit entspreche david storks
oder andere personen falschbeschuldigung
vorgang und formalitäten werden
durchgespielt immer wieder dass ich auch
ohne emotionen formen emstal großer
vorteil
da spielen sie lernen ihre theoretische
wissen praktisch anzuwenden
die realität und ein noch vier punkte zu
also
es ist jetzt einfach extrem film ersten
mal wenn sie heute morgen vom rein
taktischer spektrum glück aber jetzt
eine mitte mit der ganzen formular und
die ganze rechtliche schritte sind schon
sehr viel überlegung dahinter wohl
einfach korrekt gemacht werden also mir
persönlich fehlt eine gewisse sicherheit
beinahe
schon ein stück wieder sicherheit so
einfach sicher sagen dass straßen dass
ich das ohne dass man jetzt gesetz durch
zu hilfe und es könnte schätzt du die
große schwierigkeit zum zum motto sicher
alles abdecke
[Musik]
der nahm der trick ist es um formen
kantonspolizist darum hat er schon als
kind gelernt was verbrechen verfolgen
tag
fahrerseite
noch der praktische apps kreiert gott
sind dokr mix im home office bietet
[Musik]
die
innere blitzblank honig
ich denke schon dass minuspunkte nicht
widerspiegele und vor allem die
partnerin
wir sie einfach bei die zwei typen was
kann ordentlich hand und dann dass man
wisse wo ich die sache sind und so
ist halt
einfach dass man sie mit der versorger
so was mir nicht widersprechen
[Musik]
sie nie freunde in pädagogik
für sie passt einander wird richtig ob
in uniform
geboren politische
[Musik]
antwort
und dario in porto schoss sich richtig
und sicher auch die sportliche aspekt
also
energiewende positiv
und arbeit ganz
am liebsten gar kein fleisch aber wir
haben gute kompromiss kommen
nicht nur qualitativ lang musste wenn es
um hot dogs co
ziemlich freundin säcke titelseiten
anderweitig und viel besser mit stress
umgehen
blieben schwierige situationen ruhig und
immer korrekt zentrale eigenschaft für
ein polizist gesetz galt nämlich für sie
der beträgt geschätzte mit rechnet das
septett beobachtet
bilder von der überwachungskamera in
luzern polizist ging 2000 ritter am
morgen um vier rumänische einbrecher
immer wieder den kopf was nicht gelöst
hat es ist alles gefilmt wurde der
vorfall hat nicht nur für die elite
polizisten konsequenzen der interne
umgang damit hatte zur be tried dass der
kommandant schlussendlich hat mehrere
ordner
[Musik]
polizisten werden immer wieder zu
unrecht kritisiert die svp hat aus
nachdem ii sa 23 okt
softie hatte ihnen bargeld beschimpfe
gläser migriert verletzt und sich drei
kritzkow
ich möchte aber auch jetzt noch
das ist schon das ding mit hund sofort
legen wir zusammen ging es um sie
geworden
das hat auch serie versetzt
entschuldigung
[Musik]
organisieren vor dem abstellen
endlich
[Musik]
wird zunehmend empfindlich wenn es jetzt
still als eine wichtige ja
wie lange war man was machen
antwortoption das steht in jedem fall
nach high und sich erledigt option b
meine hirnzellen ac pharos setzt auf
einen anderen dessen hattrick als ohne
theater nach jetzt trainiere ich andere
sonstige sie bitte
die
ganz einfach wollen wir jetzt
handschellen
es ist ein sender der auch
[Musik]
wo sie wie den ersten crash sind massive
vorwürfe
man hat dann keine uni jurist erlöse
meistens langes gespräch
[Musik]
diana staehly das erstmal mit
patroullieren nur in zivil und ihrem
ausbildungsstand entsprechende
unbewaffnet im moment hat sie kreischt
system eine einwöchige praktikum ihrem
polizei
zwei erfahrene polizisten im spiel
[Musik]
ich mache mir mit dem markt aber mit der
mobile
zentrale hat uns krebs mit uns auch mal
die hand und und das mit der freibad
juli sind
dann sind wir eigentlich präventiv
unterwegs natürlich
unsere einzuwenden habe ich sagt wenn
man gar nicht aktiv oder zentraler
ansatz kriegt warten
endlich eine chance
kein anderer für zentrale 11 01 vor ort
centralia vps 11 01 mit sind vor ort
ein rentner hatte polizei erbeutete
bargeld und stier unterlage in moskau
und plötzlich sec beides verschwunden
institution haben wenn ich mich momentan
die person nicht ruhig das müsse sich
endlich endlich passiert sie haben
[Musik]
recht
polizei jetzt mit der tochter kontakt
aufnehmen und dann entscheiden wie es
weitergeht
ist relativ ruhig
so gut für alle die vaduzer sind dass es
ihnen gut geht
und wann gar nicht läuft machen es
verkehrskontrolle mit
[Musik]
tätige kontrolle sammler polizeikreisen
partikel
im 6er um 8,2 pb
mit visa und bursa verteile die welle
vertrag bereits wurde und freund und
helfer sie mit den fotos und videos von
der ausbildung sehr schöne erinnerungen
verbunden effekte auf einen neuen
lebensabschnitt sie noch sehen will er
als landmaschinenmechaniker
[Musik]
im alltag noch mächtig ins berufsleben
wir große rolle dass der polizist hat in
der bevölkerung also man wird wirklich
geglückt man wird an stelle und man
erwartet sehr fair vom ball zischt am
berner vorort ist dass man das problem
erkennt und löst also wenn politiker
wird dann hat man wirklich der
erwartungshaltung das problem versucht
lösen und das ist am anfang natürlich
sehr schwierig umzusetzen
was ist
zwischen
bund und
[Musik]
danach öffentlich
macht
der freund
unterstützt sie auf dem weg zu ihrem
traum plus die beide wüssten dass viele
erfordern die politisch das sagt die
unregelmäßige arbeitszeiten
apple aufstieg für sie und ihre sum
fällt
[Musik]
auf dass man vier richtig gute
nachrichten und vor dem haus eines
unfalls krenz du könntest ja
ich mache mir da jetzt nicht so als
hätte auch gut vor hat es so klappt und
ich denke so wird mit dem gut klappen
ich würde es mir ich
muss man darüber finden das ist dass wir
bis jetzt haben wir das recht gut
gemacht was weiß ich wenn sie mal nicht
kann hat
wenn ich mal irgendwie ein neues
weißwein oder
wenn es hat gepasst hätten hätten etwas
enttäuscht
habe der name kompromisse
sie könne sich durchsetze seit er das
umfeld sie sich fokussiert und hätten
starke wille die sekretärin kommunikativ
und empathisch also eine idealbesetzung
als polizistin auf eine gewisse tastatur
findet ungefährlich
das einzige sei eigentlich der worte von
franz pichler angestellt das was ich
sauer gemacht dass das im polizeiberuf
wie ja wenn man holt damit gewisse
risiken sich rechnen muss im
berufsalltag
genannt wird ist im moment nicht an der
polizeischule sondern um eine einwöchige
praktikum
lagebesprechung vor lisa
feller dass ich im moment durch ein
aktuelles thema umgehört in allschwil
vor allem
stellt man jetzt wieder ein verfechter
der modus operandi oder genau so
vorgehen dass wir das gelingt
es ihm möglich über halten wir jetzt
merkt dass dass es irgendwie gott zum
auto dem klingt in mehrfamilienhäuser in
den keller und denn die latte holzleiter
verschlägt dir schon spektiv die
ausschließlich und die werde mit der
entschieden oder mit resi durchschnitte
[Musik]
noch chatroom angefangen doch unschuldig
der serie brechen vermutlich wieder
zugeschlagen
[Musik]
vor ort ist unklar hier bekommt die
methode das dürfte wirklich ist
das mit trennscheiben gemacht wurde
und problem ist aufgrund von der
struktur dadurch hast stock kann ich für
sich es ist schlichtweg ein foto gemacht
vor ganz nah dass mit der trennscheibe
haft macht
was es für velux empfehlung das sind der
einzige griffel bank
sind haben wir zweimal rennvelo
ja sie kann das
[Musik]
formular mit personalien dann vergisst
sich sagen etwas das muss man alles mit
gegen und dort sind so dass man die
einfache personal in den keller
nachmittag lockt man schnell ist der mit
ihrem 19
da legen wir das noch schneller
polizei von mittwoch 1 für sich
[Musik]
als nächstes als verstärkung angefordert
anwohner verdächtige jugendliche mode wo
man jetzt wird kontrollieren
relative zugestellt nicht provozieren
gerne
grund geht es darum jetzt das mit einem
choral bergen und jetzt sagt - durch
grund verdienen dass sie so viel sind
und verkaufen von oder charlie bekannt
sind wir uns mit dem essig sehen wir
jetzt auch im elite
herstellt 112 geblieben der
kontrollierten und hätte sicher
wahnsinnig anders wir jetzt im moment
kolleg todsichere dass er enke
kontrollieren und
falls nicht dann das video zwei
beschäftigten im moment um in of pop ist
eigentlich in erster linie bei der auch
rund um blicke sind befinden feindbild
das ist so
und der versuche mir einfach klima sowie
des deeskalierend zu wirken wie es
irgend möglich ist also nicht extra
neuen träger werden und damit damit
bronze hinter eskalierten schluss und
vielfach ist eine so dass wenn du
kontrollen oder 2 denn ist das phänomen
dass sich andere
unbeteiligte
japanischen auto sich berührt oder
verbindet ja und das ist denn die
gefährlichen moment
keiner hat drogen oliver g
[Musik]
zum schluss mit note selbstunfall
das auto liegt jedoch im garten und
speziell
für zentrale 302 ich will vor ort
für die zeitliche und rené sich das
alles nicht erklären
und wenn man mal so richtig fertig weil
aufgrund von der spuren das ist stoff
wahrheit aber
nur von erfahrenen 2 haben die
schnittspuren separate visos auto im
graben gelandet ist
der linie der 86
die sind ganz normale zum ganz normalen
zustanden das muss aber nicht heißen das
heißt einfach das kollision mit so stark
obwohl es so
ja
[Musik]
ich jetzt noch mal ein absperrbaren da
nicht gemacht und dass man gesagt dass
mir so dass sie sind
der abschleppdienst echter
seit da also rausgehe
hat der landkreis vorzüglich beherrscht
oder ist es einfach ein unfall oder dem
hinteren passieren
im büro von mit polizisten lieferten
auszuwerten
aber was dort wächst was doch wichtig
sich also
schon von der politik ging da ich sage
es eigentlich nicht ins rutschen kurz
auto also das heißt es nicht um crew
vernommen und hätte diesen tag machen
das ist hier der sonne sondern reicht
die schlange
außer ich natürlich
sehr erträglich zum sehe wie mir das
ganze funktioniert jetzt einmal vor ort
termin mit seht ihr das eigentlich die
regel sehr selten und also vom vom
groben ebene
also dankeschön das so ist wenn ich mir
das vorgestellt habe dennoch überrascht
wieviel sache dass wir auch der gegner
wieviel faktor dass du mitspielen und wo
im großen und ganzen linie erwartungen
erfüllt und
so gott will
ja natürlich und im drei grad kalten
wasser die grenze
und den anstrich wird mit dem tod
konfrontiert
wir haben alles abgesperrt und erwartet
wieder hinunter auf
[Musik]